demi lovato wants you to know she does
not
care what other people say
[Music]
the singer hit up instagram to reveal
she accidentally lost weight
writing quote i don't restrict or purge
and i especially
don't live my life according to the diet
culture you have to prioritize
what's important to you demi also went
on to clarify that this particular
weight loss was a different experience
for her
revealing she felt full of peace
serenity joy
and love i'm really lucky in the past
demi has been very open with her fans
about her struggles with body image
more notably in this tweet from 2018
writing
feeling gross today at a photo shoot but
i'm choosing to accept what i see
because i love myself for who i am and
your love and support gets me through
moments like this
if you're struggling as well don't
forget if i can do it
you can do it too i think that everybody
still struggles with
something and um sometimes i'll still
struggle with
past behaviors kind of and cravings
creeping in but
you know that's when i reach out to the
people around me and they're very
supportive very caring
and they just remind me of who i am how
strong i am and
kind of recharges my confidence and
myself
and you know i feel better and of course
we'll be getting a better glimpse on
demi's journey to self-love and a whole
lot more
in her new youtube documentary demi
lovato dancing with the devil
it's just only gonna get better from
here yeah
i've snapped she was like i can't i
can't see i can't see anything
in february the singer shared how she's
learned from her past struggles with
ellen degeneres
we live in a time where nobody's perfect
and we're not going to get role models
by
watching people not make mistakes we're
going to
meet and learn from our role models who
have
overcome their deepest darkest struggles
you